بهدفي تعزيز المشاريع السياحيه والثقافيه
وتحقيق فرص اقتصاديه تنمويه تماشيا مع
رؤيه 2030 اطلقت السعوديه مؤخرا عددا من
الصناديق التي تهدف الى دعم قطعه اقتصاديه
حيويه اول هذه الصناديق مشاهدينا هو صندوق
التنميه السياحي والذي يعمل على تحقيق
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للسياحه والهادفه
الى تعزيز صوره السعوديه وجهه سياحيه
رائده عالميا ثلاثه اهداف رئيسيه لصندوق
التنميه السياحي والتي تكمن في دعم تمويل
المشاريع في المناطق الاقل نموا وتعزيز
تنميه الاقتصاديه بالاضافه الى التركيز
على استدامه راس المال الصندوق وفق ما كشف
عنه وزير السياحه احمد الخطيب في يناير
الماضي قام بتمويل 25 مشروعا خلال عام
ونصف بقيمته 15 مليار ريال ولاعطاء صوت
جديد للثقافه السعوديه مشاهدينا وتعزيز
هويتها وحفظ ارثها الحضاري ياتي دور صندوق
التنميه الثقافي الذي يهدف الى تنميه
القطاع الثقافي وتحقيق الاستدامه من خلال
دعم المشاريع الثقافيه وتسهيل الاستثمار
في الانشطه الثقافيه صندوق التنميه
الثقافي مشاهدينا سيركز على دعم 16 قطاعا
ثقافيا من خلال برامج تنمويه باليات تمويل
مختلفه
ولتعزيز مكانه السعوديه مشاهدينا مركزا
عالميا الفعاليات والاحداث المتنوعه
المرتبطه بقطاعات الثقافه والسياحه
والترفيه وكذلك الرياضه الامير محمد بن
سلمان اعلن عن اطلاق صندوق الفعاليات
الاستثماري والذي يهدف الى الاسهام في
الناتج المحلي بثمانيه وعشرين مليار ريال
بحلول العام
45 من خلال تنويع مصادر الدخل غير الن كما
يهدف مشاهدينا هذا الصندوق بشكل اساسي
لتطوير اكثر من 35 موقعا في السعوديه
وزياده فرص الاستثمار المباشره لشركات
والبنوك العالميه وتوفير 160 الف وظيفه
ولاجل تمكين مشاركه القطاع الخاص من
الاستثمار بمشاريع البنيه التحتيه في
السعوديه وتعزيز جاذبيه الفرص الاستثماريه
للمشاريع ياتي دور صندوق البنيه التحتيه
لدعم المشاريع في القطاعات الحيويه كالنقل
والمياه والطاقه والصحه والتعليم
والاتصالات وكذلك البنيه التحتيه الرقميه
وغيرها مما سينعكس ايجابا على تنميه
الاقتصاد الوطني ويعزز من جوده الحياه تصل
مشاهدينا قيمه المبالغ المرصوده في
الصندوق لدعم المشروعات الى 200 مليار
ريال على مدى السنوات العشر المقبله الامر
الذي يسهم في تنميه الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي وتوفير فرص للعمل